[Musique]
dans les couloirs du centre de contrôle
de tchernobyl des restes d'ordinateurs
des rues son nom détruit près de 600
juste avant leur départ début avril ils
auront passé trente cinq jours dans la
zone d'exclusion
il y avait des serveurs
ils ont été volés
les ordinateurs ont été détruits en plus
de l'équipement les logiciels ont été
volés
il observait à parer à toute situation
inhabituelle
par exemple
s'il ya un incendie dans la zone
d'exclusion
les taux de radiation sont mesurés dans
ce laboratoire pendant l'occupation
russe le contact avec des dizaines de
détecteurs sur les trente neuf que
compte le site a été perdu cet
équipement spécial fourni par l'union
européenne et d'une valeur de 6 millions
et demi d'euros et d'aujourd'hui horde
usage le logiciel qui permet de le faire
fonctionner a été volé
c'est du vandalisme
ne voulaient clairement pas que cet
équipement soit utilisé dans le futur
aujourd'hui la situation est à peu près
revenu à la normale les détecteurs
fonctionnent les niveaux de radiation
sont conformes à ceux enregistrés avant
le début de la guerre ont février comme
l'a notamment confirmé l' agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
mais l'équipement avec lequel le
personnel travaille et d'un autre temps
on a récupéré tout ce qu'on pouvait et
nous nous sommes attelés à la tâche afin
de pouvoir reprendre la relève des
mesures et surveiller la zone
d'exclusion
nous avons tout reconstruit à partir de
ce qui reste est utilisé tout ce qui
pouvait l'être même ses disquettes
nous faisons avec les moyens du bord
coût estimé du remplacement de tout ce
qui a été volés ou détruits près de 135
millions de dollars
aujourd'hui seuls deux employés sur les
60 que compte normalement le laboratoire
peuvent travailler
la menace militaire russe existe
toujours cela signifie que la vie des
gens ici est toujours menacée
tout débute le 24 février date de
l'invasion de l'ukraine les russes
prennent le contrôle du site nucléaire
[Musique]
pendant plus d'un mois environ 90
employés vont continuer à travailler à
surveiller la centrale nucléaire sous
l'oeil menaces sont des russes
oleksandr on faisait partie
voilà la pagaille qu'ils ont laissé
derrière eux
et voilà comment c'était dans tous les
bureaux début mars la centrale est
privée d'électricité
sans elle impossible de refroidir le
combustible nucléaire les russes
finissent par fournir du fuel pour
alimenter les générateurs à nouvel
épisode angoissant pour les employés
c'était très confus ici il tirait des
coups de feu se cacher derrière la
centrale c'était extrêmement dangereux
difficile pour oleksandr d'évoquer ces
moments de captivité prisonnier des
russes est coupé du monde
vous êtres happés vous renversez vous
forcer à vous allongé sur le sol avec
une mitrailleuse braqué dans le dos ils
demandaient qui vous étiez où vous
alliez il fouillait dans votre téléphone
et dans vos poches vous deviez chercher
une issue comment survivre et tenter de
savoir ce qui arrivait à votre famille
alors qu'il n'y avait aucun réseau et
que vous ne pouviez pas savoir ce qui se
passait en dehors d'ici et puis on
voyait arriver tous ces équipements
militaires d avion volé un flot de chars
arrivé sans en voir la fin
depuis 2000 tout le site a été mise à
l'arrêt mais il reste extrêmement
sensible
autour du réacteur numéro 4 qui a
explosé en 1986 le fameux sarcophage
impossible de filmer de très près les
lieux sont gardés et nous sommes
accompagnés par une guide officiel sur
ce territoire radioactifs qui s'étend
sur une trentaine de kilomètres c'est
ici à tchernobyl pas très loin de la
centrale nucléaire est juste à côté de
l'entrée de la forêt rouge que des
soldats russes ont décidé de s'installer
d'installer des positions juste ici
qu'ils ont creusée dans un sol
totalement contaminés on n'est pas près
plusieurs témoins il serait resté vivre
ici jusqu'à trois semaines ils
mangeaient buvaient et dormi ici
et c'est ça qui sont remplis de sable
radioactifs qui l'ont extrait pause pour
votre campagne et tout
ils ont tout de même apporté leur propre
sac
à ce jour il n'y a aucune information
sur l'état de santé des troupes qui ont
occupé tchernobyl
l'armée ukrainienne a repris le contrôle
du site et à restera presque tous les
accès
avant la guerre locaux vides il était
possible de visiter une partie de
tchernobyl et la ville de pripiat où
habitait les employés de la centrale
avant l'accident une attraction
touristique majeure en 2019 le site
avait accueilli 124 mille visiteurs
je voudrais que tout rentre dans l'ordre
que les touristes puissent revenir et
que la région se développe mais je ne
sais pas ce que l'avenir nous réserve
le temps pareil ici comme suspendu
et pourtant non loin chacun continue de
s'activer pour préserver le site
le personnel reste sur ses gardes la
guerre est toujours en cours les russes
reviendront-ils
l'incertitude persiste